[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
مرشح للانتخابات التركيه الخاسر سنان
اوغان يحدد شروطه لدعم اردوغان
اوغلو في جوله الاعاده
مستوى التضخم في السعوديه يستقر عند اثنين
فاصله سبعه للشهر الثاني على التوالي
الجمارك السعوديه تحبط محاوله تهريب مليون
و300 الف حبه كبتاجون عبر ميناء جده
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه ايضا
البيئه السعوديه تكشف عن تسجيل اعلى متوسط
لهطول الامطار منذ اربعين عاما في
السعوديه في ابريل الماضي
5000 ريال مخالفه عدم استخدام العنوان
الوطني من قبل مقدمي الخدمات البريديه في
السعوديه
حياكم الله نبدا الرابع من اخر تطورات
الانتخابات التركيه حيث اعلنت هيئه
الانتخابات التركيه بانه لا فائزه في
انتخابات امس معلنه الذهاب لجوله اعاده
يوم الثامن والعشرين من مايو الهيئه اضافت
بان اردوغان حصل على
49.51%
وكليجدار اوغلو على اربعه واربعين فاصله
88% كما اعلنت هيئه الانتخابات التركيه عن
فرز مئه في المئه من الاصوات وبان نسبه
المشاركين وصلت الى 88.92%
وفي التطورات ايضا اكد المرشح الرئاسي
الحاصل على المركز الثالث في انتخابات
الرئاسه التركيه سنان اوغان انه مستعد
للتفاوض مع اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو لدعم
احدهما في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
وقال ايضا ان مواجهه الارهاب واعاده
اللاجئين اهم نقاط التفاوض مع اردوغان
وكليجدد واضاف انه مستعد لدعم كليجدار
اوغلو اذا امتنع عن تقديم تنازلات للاكراد
مشيرا الى ان مرشحه تحالف المعارضه اوغلو
لم ينجح في اقناع الشعب
مين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وكشفت الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه عن فوز
اردوغان باحدى وخمسين مقاطعه مقابل 30
لمرشح المعارضه كمال
في تفاصيل ذلك خسر اردوغان اهم مقاطاعتين
وهما اسطنبول وانقره بعد انتصار كليجدار
اوغلو فيهما بفارق ضئيل كذلك تمكن مرشح
المعارضه من السيطره على جميع المقاطعات
شرق تركيا تقريبا وبعض الولايات في الجنوب
الغربي بينما سيطر اردوغان على مقاطعات
الوسط والشمال ابرزها واكبرها مقاطعه
قونيا وكان لافتا ايضا فوزا كليجدار اوغلو
في بعض الولايات التي تضررت بنكبه الزلزال
مثلها طاي واضنه بينما فاز اردوغان في
ولايات اخرى متضرره كشارلي اورفا وغازي
عنتاب
اعلن رئيس وهيئه الانتخابات في تركيا احمد
يانر اللجوء الى جوله اعاده لحسم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لاول مره في تاريخ
تركيا وستكون جوله الاعاده المقرره في 28
من مايو بين رجب طيب اردوغان الذي حصل على
49.51% من الاصوات ومرشح المعارضه كمال
كليجدار اوغلو الذي حصل على
44.88 بعد فرز 100% من الصناديق وقال يانر
ان كلا المرشحين يمكنهما البدء بالدعايه
الانتخابيه على الفور وفقا للنتائج
والان مع شبكه مفادي العربيه من اسطنبول
ينضم الينا وفد العربيه طاهر بركه من انكر
فاطمه فهد ومن كهرما مرعش غسان مرحبا بكم
جميعا معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ابدا
معك فاطمه من انقره اذا الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات اعلنت فرز كل النتائج حتى هذه
اللحظه وبالتالي نسال هنا عن جوله الاعاده
كيف ستكون اليتها من يتنافس ايضا فيها هل
ذات القواعد في الجوله الاولى
تتشابه كليا مع جوله الاعاده فاطمه
[تصفيق]
فاطمه
طيب
يبدو ان زميله فاطمه لا تسمعني سنحاول
العوده اليها مره اخرى حاله تجاوزنا هذا
الخلل الفني اعود الى اسطنبول الى طاهر
بركه طاهر مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى من جديد
انت موجود منذ الصباح في الشارع بين الناس
ايضا
ما الذي يتحدث به الناس بعد فرز النتائج
بنسبه 100% طاهر عن ماذا يتحدثون عن
الانتخابات عن المرشحين عن البرامج ايضا
كذلك
تدور نقاشات كثيره امامنا منذ الصباح
الباكر وطيله ايام وجودنا في تركيا لتغطيه
هذه الانتخابات بين الناس هنا ومن العادي
جدا ان تجد يعني شخصين
يعني يعارضان بعضهما البعض في المواقف
السياسيه يتحدثان قبل قليل شاهدت على
شخصين كان يتحدثان عن الاجور عن موضوع
الاقتصاد وقلنا مرارا انه احد مواضيع
الساعه ويمكن ان نشاهد زحمه الناس من
خلفنا في ميدان الحريه في بكر كوي كان
الاول يقول للثاني ان الحد الادنى للاجور
لا يتناسب مع الايجارات خصوصا في اسطنبول
الايجار هنا 5000 ليره لاستوديو صغير جدا
نايف ما يقارب 250 دولارا امريكيا في
مراتب 8000 ليره نحو 400 دولار فكيف تكفي
لفواتيرنا ومواصلاتنا وطعامنا وشرابنا يرد
عليه الاكبر سنا يقول انت عشت جيلك لم تعش
جيلنا نحن لو عشت جيلنا لم تمكنت من فعل
شيء لانهم عاشوا حياه اصعب يقول كنا ناتي
بالمياه بالصهاريج الى منازلنا انظر الى
الكافيهات والى الاسواق والى البنى
التحتيه الان يقصد فتره اردوغان في الحكم
فيرد عليه الاخر يعني لا اجد اناسا لا
يجدون وظائف هنا ندخل في موضوع اللاجئين
النقطه الثانيه التي مرارا ما قلنا انها
تؤثر كثيرا في هذه الانتخابات ما كنا
نقوله كعناوين عريضه ونحاول شرحه هو صلب
نقاشات الاتراك فيما بينهم في المقاهي وفي
البيوت وفي كل المؤسسات هذا عامل مهم جدا
بالنسبه اليهم ودائما ما يتحدثون عنه
وبالتالي هذه محددات اساسيه ستكون بين
الاتراك فيما يتعلق بالجوله الثانيه لانها
لم تتغير ان كان موضوع الاقتصاد لن يتغير
في ليله وضحاها وان كان موضوع اللاجئين
اما المتغيرات الاخرى مثل المواضيع التي
يعني تفرض نفسها على الساحه الان فهي
المتعلقه بالمرشح الثالث وما حصل عليه
والى اين ستتجه اصواته او يعني ايضا من
المترددين بين الرجلين سنعود للحديث عن ما
قاله سنان اوغن معك طاهر لكن نعود مره
اخرى الى انقره الى فاطمه فهد فاطمه كنت
اسال عن اليه اعاده
الانتخابات كيف سيكون شكل هذه الاليه هل
ستقتصر فقط على الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
الحالي ام على
طبعا مرشح المعارضه كذلك امن كل من تسابق
ودخل في هذه
الانتخابات واتحدث عن سنان اوغن ايضا كذلك
بانه سينضم الى هذه الجوله الثانيه ام لا
في الجوله الثانيه فقط ستكون قصرا على رجب
طيب اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو لانهم
المرشحين لذا حصل على اعلى ارقام سنان لن
يكون ضمن هذه الجوله الثانيه طبعا الجوله
الثانيه ستكون ايضا مختصره على الرئاسه
فقط لم يكن هناك اي انتخابات نواب او
برلمان البرلمان اصبح من نصيب العداله
والتنميه والاحزاب المواليه لهم بالتالي
اصبحت يعني المعادله اصعب بالنسبه لكدار
اوغلو والمعارضه لانه يعني يرى بعض
المحللون ان اذا كان البرلمان من نصيب
الحزب الحاكم
فاطمه الطيب سنحاول تجاوز هذا
مع زميله فاطمه اتفضل اكمل اعاده الصوره
مره اخرى
كنت اقول بان بعض الاراء تتحدث عن ان لو
انتهت الانتخابات في الجوله الاولى لاصبحت
الهزيمه لاحد عشر بالنسبه لك للجدار ولكن
ما ان ذهب للجوله الثانيه فانها ستكون
الهزيمه الثانيه عشر له ويقولون لم يشبع
من الهزائم اذا راي اخر يقول بانك رجال
اوغلو يدخل في نفق مظلم في الجوله الثانيه
يعني نستمع الى تفاؤل كبير من جانب الحزمه
الحاكم ومناصريه وربما بعض من الاحباط
وخيبه الامل من مناصري المعارضه حتى الان
والجدير بالذكر انهم غالبا ما يعني تنتظر
حتى تعلن النتائج النهائيه بعد انتهاء
المهله المعطاه للطعن بالانتخابات وهي
كانت الى غدا الثلاثه مساء ولكن تم
الاعلان عن النتائج النهائيه اليوم لانهم
يقولون بان هناك لا تغيير في نسبه
الانتخابات بالتالي لا داعي للانتهاء او
الانتظار حتى الانتهاء من مهله الطعن طبعا
مهله الطعن هذه ايضا ستكون موجوده في
الجوله الثانيه سيتم اعطائهم مهله 72 ساعه
تقريبا ليتم الطعن في اي نتائج انتخابيه
وايضا سيحق للمصوتون من الخارج للتصويت
كذلك في الجوله الثانيه غسان اغلبيه ساحقه
لاردوغان في كهرمان مرعش لماذا
نايف اكثر من 71% حصل عليها اردوغان في
ولايه كهرمان مرعش ولايه كهرمان مرعش
لطالما كانت تصوت للرئيس اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه في السنوات السابقه وهي
معروفه يعني تميل للرئيس اردوغان وبالتالي
حصل على هذه الاصوات وكان ايضا حزب
العداله والتنميه قد حصل على سته مقاعد من
اصل ثمانيه مقاعد هي نصيب ولايه كهرمان
مرعش في الانتخابات البرلمانيه السابقه
عام 2018 وبالتالي ما زال اردوغان وحزب
التنميه يحافظ على حضوره في هذه الولايه
حتى هذه اللحظه في الامس كان هناك
احتفالات بدات مبكرا بعد يعني بدايه الفرز
بساعه تقريبا واستمرت لساعات الليل
المتاخره حيث انا اقف هنا خلفي هناك مقر
حزب العداله والتنميه هنا تجمهره المئات
ربما الالاف واح لساعات طويله في هذا
الفوز واعتبروه بانه فوز ساحق لهم في هذه
الولايه خصوصا بعد الظروف التي مروا فيها
وبالتالي هم يقولون ان حتى لو الانتخابات
اتجهت الى جوله ثانيه فانهم سيعيدون
الانتخاب او انتخاب الرئيس اردوغان نايف
طاهر يعني الان نحن في طور التجهيز لهذه
الجوله جوله الاعاده بالنسبه لتصريحات
المرشح الثالث
ما الذي تعنيه الان ما الذي تعنيه بالنسبه
الى تحالفه ايضا كذلك استمعت طاهر الى
تصريحاته
ظهر اليوم
طبعا
سنان تصريحاته مهمه ويلعب على الخطين الان
اذا صح التعبير هو يشترط ان يكون هناك
يعني تاكيد على موضوع الحرب على الارهاب
كشرط والشرط الثاني الذي يضعه سنان اوغان
متعلق ايضا باعاده توطين اللاجئين لانه
ينتسب الى قوميين متشددين في فكرهم فيما
يتعلق بوجود اللاجئين الان هذان الشرطان
بحد ذاتهما قد يكونان متناقضين اذا ما اصر
على مكافحه ما يسميه بالارهاب سيكون لديه
مشكله مع كيف يقنعنا اخي به بالتصويت الذي
يدعمه اليسار الاخضر حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي اي الاكراد الجناح السياسي
لحزب العمال الكردستاني الذي يتهمه
بالارهاب اما اذا اصر على اعاده توطين
اللاجئين فسيكون لديه مشكله مع من الرجل
الثاني المرشح الثاني الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الرئيس الحالي لانه يريد ان
يتعامل مع الموضوع برويه ولا يريد اعاده
اللاجئين وخطابها اهدا بكثير في هذا
الموضوع من خطاب الذي يعني تدعمه احزاب
تريد اعاده اللاجئين وربما يرقى البعض
ببعض الخطابات المتشدده الى طرد اللاجئين
لانهم يؤثرون على اقتصاد البلاد بالدرجه
الاولى اذا هنا السؤال ما الذي
يعني يؤثر سنان اوغان ان يكون الاولويه
بالنسبه اليه الحرب على الارهاب
وبالتالي يدعم اردوغان في هذه النقطه ولا
يدعم لانه الاكراد يدعموه او القوى
الكرديه يعني المعنيه بهذا الموضوع بشكل
اساسي او يفضل اعاده توطين اللاجئين
كعنوان عريض وبالتالي يدعم كليتش وهنا لا
يقتصر الامر على خياره هو فقط لا ننسى لا
ننسى بان هناك الكثير من الاصوات التي
ذهبت وهي كانت مف اجئه كانسبه حصل عليها
سنان اوغان ذهبت اليه ليس لشخصه وليس
لحزبه وليس لتحالفه وانما كان هناك هاربون
من التحالفات الاخرى ربما ايضا تتشتت
الاصوات في المره المقبله عندما ناتي الى
الجوله الثانيه في 28 من مايو بانتظار ذلك
فاطمه ماذا عن تصريحات المعارضه بعد هذه
الانتخابات سريعا
حقيقه تصريحات يعني في محاوله لربما يعني
تضمين الشعب وتضمين المناصرين لهم
في تصريح وقال يعني شعبي العزيز نحن نعمل
منذ امس بلا توقف اياكم والياس فانا لا
زلت واقفا منتصبا ساشرح لكم بالتفصيل اخر
المستجدات وبعدها سنقف مجددا وسنفوز بتلك
الانتخابات وفي النهايه سيصير الامر كما
رغب شعبنا اذا هذه محاوله
منكروا في اعمالهم ويستمروا في التصويت
والا يحولوا اصواتهم لصالح الحزب الحاكم
نايف غسان تداعيات الزلزال هل اثرت على
اصوات الناخبين في هذه الانتخابات خصوصا
في كهرمان مرعش وباختصار ايضا
ليس كثيرا نايف لم تؤثر كثيرا لكن هناك
مطالب
بالاسراء تامين المنازل التي وعد بها
الرئيس اردوغان وهناك من حاول ان يلعب
خصوصا المعارضه بهذه الورقه لاحاوله
محاوله خلق الشرع شرخ عفوا داخل صفوف
ولايه كارمان مرعش من الناخبين المؤيدين
الى اردوغان لكن على ما يبدو ان النتائج
اثرت عكس ذلك نايف شكرا جزيلا لكم شبكه
مراسله العربيه من كرمه مرعش غساله باللوز
من انقره فاطمه فهد ومن اسطنبول طاهر بركه
شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام 2018 حرز 295 مقعدا عام 2023
تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حيث 146
مقعدا عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حازت 49
مقعدا عام 2023 حاز 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد
عام 2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44
مقعدا حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاز 67
مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 61 مقعده
رابع مستمر فيها
مستوى التضخم في السعوديه يستقر عند 2.7%
للشهر الثاني على التوالي
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد تمكنت هيئه الزكاه
والضريبه والجمارك السعوديه في ميناء جده
من احباط محاوله تهريب كميه من حبوب
الكبتاجون بلغت اكثر من مليون و300 الف
حبه كبتاجون عثر عليها مخباه في ارساليه
الواح خشبيه
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه سجل معدل التضخم اثنين وسبعه
اعشار في المئه على اساس سنوي في ابريل
دون تغيير عن الشهر السابق وذلك حسب تقرير
حكومي صادر اليوم التفاصيل مع زميل العنود
العبدلي
سجل تضخمه في السعوديه في ابريل الماضي
استقرارا وذلك للشهر الثاني على التوالي
عند اثنين وسبعه اعشار في المئه ومنخفضا
عند مستويات يناير الماضي والتي بلغت
ثلاثه واربعه اعشار في المئه اي بانخفاض
بلغ سبعه اعشار في المئه التضخم في ابريل
من عام 23 سجل ارتفاعا طفيفا عند مقارنته
بنفس الشهر من العام الماضي حيث جاء هذا
ارتفاع مشاهدينا مدعوما بشكل اساسي
بارتفاع يسعى السكن والكهرباء والماء
والغاز بنسبه ثمانيه وعشرين في المئه
بالاضافه لارتفاع اسعار الاغذيه
والمشروبات بنسبه واحد في المئه لنرى الان
مشاهدينا بالارقام كيف اثرت اسعار
الايجارات على التضخم في شهر ابريل عام 23
مقارنه بشهر ابريل من العام الماضي فكما
نرى هنا ارتفعت الايجارات الفعليه للمساكن
بنسبه وسته اعشار في المئه في شهر اب من
العام الحالي جاء هذا ارتفاع مشاهدينا
مدعوما بزياده اسعار جرارات الشقق بنسبه
22 وعشرين في المئه واسعار الاغذيه
والمشروبات هي الاخرى سجلت ارتفاعا بنسبه
واحد في المئه كما سجل قسم النقل ارتفاعا
بلغ تثبته مشاهدينا واحدا وعشرا في المئه
وذلك مقارنه بشهر ابريل من العام الماضي
سجل قسم المطاعم والفنادق ارتفاعا بنسبه
سته اعشار وعشرين في المئه اما قسم
التعليم فقد سجل ارتفاعا بنسبه ثلاثه في
المئه لنرى الان كيف ارتفعت اسعار
المستهلك في شهر ابريل من العام الحالي
مقارنه بشاي مارس الماضي سجل مؤشر اسعار
مستهلك ارتفاعا طفيفا في شهر ابريل من عام
20 23 بالنسبه 4 اعشار في المئه مقارنه
بشهر مارس من النفس العام جاء هذا
مشاهدينا مدعوما بارتفاع الايجارات
الفعليه للمساكن بنسبه سته اعشار في المئه
واسعار الاغذيه والمشروبات
بنسبه اربعه في المئه وقسم الترفيه
والثقافه بنسبه 82
ياتي هذا بعد او ياتي بعد ذلك مشاهدينا
القسم السلع والخدمات الشخصيه المتنوعه
التي ارتفعت هي الاخرى بنسبه بنسبه اربعه
اعشار في المئه وقسم الملابس ارتفع بنسبه
ثمانيه اعشار في المئه واذا نظرنا
مشاهدينا لنسبه التضخم في السعوديه شهريا
منذ ابريل الماضي نجد ان معي الماضي كان
الاقل خلال 12 شهرا الماضيه عند 22% فيما
سجل الاعلى في يناير الماضي عند 43
فيما كان معدل تضخم فوق ثلاثه في المئه
خلال الاشهر الخمسه الاخيره منذ العام
الماضي عدا نوفمبر الذي سجل 62%
من الرياض بدايه كيف تقرا هذه الارقام
للتضخم في السعوديه الشهر الماضي
والاسباب الارتفاع اللي هي مقنعه اهلا
خنافه بالساده المشاهدين انا اعتقد بانه
اذا تتبعنا من بدايه السنه 2020 23 ولاحظ
بان كان مرتفع ثلاثه فاصل اربعه بعد ذلك
نزل الى ثلاثه في المئه الان نتحدث في
مارس كان 2.7 الان اثنين فاصله سبعه يعتبر
مستقر لهذا الشهر شهرين على التوالي لذلك
انا اعتقد اذا لاحظنا حديث وزير الماليه
في وقت سابق يتحدث بان المستهدفات لنسبه
التضخم في العام 2020 هي ما بين اثنين ونص
الى اثنين فاصله سته لذلك انا استطيع ان
اقول بانه ضمن المستهدفات التي تنتهجها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واذا نظرنا على
مستوى العالمي اذا هو يظل ضمنا اقل
المستويات عالميا اذا ما قارنا المملكه
بمجموعه لذلك انا اعتقد هو ما زال تحت
السي وارقام انا اعتقد يعني ضمن
المستهدفات اثنين الى ثلاثه في المئه كثير
هو يعني مستهدفات لكثير من ارتفاع اسعار
الايجارات المساكن انخفاضها دائما هو
الترمومتر
الانخفاض او الارتفاع لماذا هل هذا مبرر
اصلا هل ربطها في التضخم ووجودها ضمن احد
العوامل التي تحدد ارتفاع نسبه التضخم او
انخفاضها هل هو صحيح برايك سؤال مهم
واستراتيجي اليوم اذا شاهدنا بان تقريبا
25.2.1% هي من سله التضخم هي تذهب الى
العقار تذهب الى الكهرباء تذهب الى الماء
والغاز انا يعتقد هي نسبه كبيره ولكن في
وجهه نظري على الاقل اتمنى بما ان ما يحرك
هذه النسبه هبوطا وصعودا هو العقار او هي
الايجارات الشقق انا اتمنى بانها تفرد
بنسبه مئويه منفصله عن الكاتيجوري ز او عن
المؤشر ليكن الكهرباء والماء والغاز عباره
عن صنف وياتي العقار مثلا والشقق او ما له
علاقه بالجانب العقاري حتى تؤثر هذه يعني
مثلا لو فصلت انا اعتقد يعطي صوره اكبر
واشمل يعطي صناع القرار ما هي المؤشرات
التي ادت الى رفع هذا المؤشر ما هي
الاسباب التي ادت الى هبوطه حتى معالجه
مثل هذه الامور انا اعتقد بانها ترسم صوره
اقتصاديه واضحه لاحدى المؤشرات التي نلاحظ
وخاصه في الفتره الاخيره يعتبر محرك مهم
لنسبه التضخم صعودا وهبوطا ممتاز
التضخم لم يتراجع حتى الان حتى مع رفع نسب
الفائده من قبل الفيدرالي الامريكي وهذه
السياسات النقديه المتشدده وايضا حتى اللي
تبع فيها
البنك المركزي السعودي هل نعز هذا لانه
هذا الرفع في نسبه الفائده لم يستطع مثلا
السيطره على التضخم او انخفاض هذه النسبه
ام لانه احنا اصلا ما وصلنا لمراحل متقدمه
في التضخم مثل ما حدث في اوروبا في امريكا
في غيرها وبالتالي هذه السياسات النقديه
لا تؤثر بشكل مباشر على نسب التضخم لدينا
نعم طبعا لابد يفرق ما بين الهياكل
الاقتصاديه للدول المتقدمه والدول الناشئه
والدول الناميه مثلا الهيكل الاقتصادي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو مختلف عن
الهيكل الاقتصادي في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مثلا نحن تلعب الايرادات النفطيه
دور مهم والان بصدد الايرادات غير النفطيه
ولكن في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الايرادات هي كلها قادمه من الضرائب بشكل
اكبر لذلك انا اعتقد بان بحكم ربط الريال
بالدولار فنحن نتبع سياسه الفيدرالي من
ناحيه السياسات الماليه مساحه السياسات
النقديه سواء تشدديه او توسعيه وبما ان
الفيدرالي يرفع نسب الفائده هذا اقتصاديا
يطلق عليه سياسه نقديه تشدديه ولكن
السؤال المهم لماذا نرفع على الرغوه بان
معدلات التضخم عندنا ضمن النطاق المستهدف
لماذا نرفع والمعدلات التضخم جيده لدينا
لا نستطيع حقيقه الا الرفع بخلاف هذا
الامر فان كثير من الاستثمارات او او من
الاموال ستخرج من الاقتصاد لتذهب تبحث عن
نسب الفائده المرتفعه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك نحن نرفع من اجل هذا السبب
ولكن تقوم المملكه لعمل توازن تذهب الى
سياسات ماليه توسعيه للخلق توازن ما بين
هذا التشدد وهذا الانفتاح وهذا خلق لدينا
حقيقه هذا النوع من التوازن وانا بحقيقه
اؤكد لك بان السياسات ما تقوم بها وزاره
الماليه
والبنك المركزي السعودي هو عمل عظيم جبار
خلق هذه الخلطه من التوازن بان يكون
معدلات التضخم ضمن المستهدفه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر كان معي هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
الاقتصادي الدكتور علي الحازمي شكرا يا
دكتور
اكدت هيئه النقل السعوديه ان عدم التزامي
مقدم الخدمه باستخدام العنوان الوطني
للمستفيدين عند تقديمه اي من الخدمات
البريديه يعد مخالفه
تستوجب العقوبه وذلك وفقا لللائحه
التنفيذيه لنظام البريد التي حددت قيمه
هذه المخالفه بخمسه الاف ريال بهدف ضمان
تطبيق افضل الممارسات وتحسين تجربه
المستفيدين ووضع الادوات النظاميه
المناسبه لحمايه الانشطه والخدمات
البريديه وتطويرها وتنميتها ايضا
وينضموا الينا هنا في الاستوديو المتحدث
الرسمي للهيئه العامه للنقل صالح زويد
حياك الله استاذ صالح معفن الرابع من
الرياض هذا القرار هذا الالزام هل يعني
انه نهايه ما يسميه البعض بالمعاناه مع
المناديب وارسل لي الموقع وصوره البيت وما
الى ذلك العين انه خلاص هذه حقبه راحت
وبكل تاكيد اليوم العنوان الوطني المختصر
هو بدايه لمرحله جديده من تسهيل الخدمات
على المستفيدين من من مختلف المجالات سواء
في التجاره الالكترونيه بالوثائق الحكوميه
او بالاستخدمات الشخصيه اليوم العنوان
الوطني المختصر خلي يقول يسهل او نظام
العين بشكل عام يسهل العمليات اللوجستيه
يرفع من كفاءه العمليات التشغيليه للشركات
اللوجستيه ايضا يسهل حياتنا اليوم
المعاناه اللي يمكن يمر فيها بعض سواء في
الطلبات اليوميه من المتاجر عمليه العنونه
الوطنيه المختصار يسهل على العملية عنوان
الوطني اللي موجود في في ابشر واللي انت
العنوان الوطني المختصر هو جزء من العنوان
الوطني الاساسي وعنوان مختصر سهل الحفظ
اربع ارقام واربع حروف تسهل حياتك في كل
مناحيها تطلب من متجر الكتروني تضعه راح
توصلك الى باب بيتك بكل سهوله دون الحاجه
للتواصل مع هذا المندوب واذا حال المندوب
تواصل او رغب انه يتزوده بمشاركه موقع
براي برامج وبرامجه بيحق لك ترفع شكوى في
الهيئه العامه نقل لان هذا احد المخالفات
اللي نصت عليها اللائحه بمعنى انه لو انا
مثلا طلبت من اي متجر وتواصل معي المندوب
التوصيل وقال لي ابعث لي الموقع او رقم
الشقه او البيت او حتى اتصل فيك هاتفيا في
هذه الحاله تستطيع انك ترفع شكوى وتغير
المندوب مباشره صحيح في حال انه كان
التواصل للعنوان في هناك احتياج لتواصل
احيانا في وقت التوصيل
مساء صباحا الى اخره لكن نتكلم اليوم عن
العنونه بحيث انه فعلا يصل الى باب بيتك
دون الحاجه التواصل الشخصي بينك وبينه
الهيئه العامه للنقل اليوم بصفه المشرفه
على قطاع البريد لديه العديد من مبادرات
لتطوير هذا القطاع من بينها كان اعتماد 77
مخالفه في نظام البريد بحيث تساعدنا في
رفع مستوى الزام الشركات المرخصه في هذا
القطاع وهناك مخالفات متعدده سواء بدايه
بممارسه الاعمال بدون التراخيص او مثلا
عدم المحافظه للمعلومات السريه ونقل مواد
محظوره او غيرها وايضا عدم التزام بتفعيل
العنوان الوطني والزام المناديب بهذا
التفعيل هدفنا اليوم فعلا الكل مواطن كل
مقيم كل شخص في هذه المملكه انه يستخدم
هذا العنوان ليس فقط في الطلبات حتى في
اليوم لما اروح لاي مكان بدل ما اوصف مكان
او اسوي مشاركه لموقف مكان بالامكان ان
يكون هذا اسلوب حياه هذه الاربعه ارقام
واربع حروف توصل
خليني اسالك سؤال يساله بعض الناس وبعض
اللي يتابعوا
القرارات او الالتزامات اللي تصدر من
الهيئه العامه للنقل يعني البعض يقول مثلا
انه الملاحظه على بعض ما تسترونا بشكل
الزامنا لا يطبق مثلا
اعتماد زي مخصص لسائقين الاجره او
التطبيقات التوصيل مثلا وذكرتهم في وقت
سابق وانه في المنقل الكل نقول البعض ما
يلتزم مثلا بهذا الالزام الزام مثلا
الشاحنات في وقت سابق بحواجز السلام
وغيرها فبالتالي يبدا يسال هنا يقول ما
الذي يضمن ان يتم تطبيق هذا الالزام الزام
التطبيقات
التوصيل او ايضا المناديب بانهم يلتزموا
بهذا الكود او هذا العنوان الوطني وهذا
وهذا اليوم هدفنا جميعا هدف وطني هدف فعلا
مثل ما تكون في انظمه على الورق جميله
تطبق ايضا على ارض الواقع ذكرت موضوعين
موضوع الزي المعتمد وموضوع الشاحنات زي
الشاحنات اليوم نسبه امتثال الشركات في
سيارات الاجره مثال السنه الماضيه كان 85%
اليوم ارتفع اثنين وتسعين في المئه في 22
في 20 22 هذا مؤشر يعطينا لن نستطيع
معالجه الكل
بتدريجيا لكن اليوم بدينا في خطوه اليوم
لما افصل اي قرار هو استنادا على ممارسات
عالميه ارغب بتطبيقها جوده خدمه اسعى
لرفعها رضا مواطن ومستفيد اسعى لتطبيقه
وجود اليوم مثلا حواجز السلامه للشاحنات
فعلا هناك كوارث تكون بسبب عدم التزام بعض
الشاحنات مثلا مثل حواجز عمر تشغيلي غير
وجود فرق رقابه وجود مخالفات وجود ايضا
مواطن ومقيم واعي يساعدنا في عمليه رفع
الشكاوى في عمليه الابلاغ عن هؤلاء
المخالفين وتقييم الخدمات يساعدنا في هذا
الشيء اشكرك جزيل الشكر كان معي هنا في
الاستوديو المتحدث الرسمي للهيئه العمل
النقل صالح بن ابراهيم الزويد شكرا
يبدا رائد الفضاء السعوديان ريان برناوي
وعلي القرني رحلتهم العلميه الى الفضاء
الاحد المقبل في الحادي والعشرين من الشهر
الجاريه الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء اعلنت بان
هذه الرحله تاتي ضمن برنامج السعوديه
لرواد الفضاء الذي تم اطلاقه في سبتمبر من
العام الماضي وتتضمن اجراء 14 تجربه بحثيه
علميه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى
اكدت رئيسه جامعه السعوديه الالكترونيه
الدكتوره ليلى الصفدي ان اطلاق الجامعه
لتخصصات مزدوجه وفرعيه سيساهم بشكل رئيسي
في تعمق الطالبات في تخصصات مختلفه مبينه
ان تخصص المزدوج يتيح للطالب الحصول من
خلاله على تخصص رئيسي اخر بالاضافه لتخصصه
الاساسي
بالنسبه للتخصص المزدوج هو برنامج اكاديمي
يتيح للطالب دراسه اكثر من تخصص في نفس
الوقت ويتطلب الحصول على درجه التخصص
المزدوج انهاء متطلبات التخصص الرئيس
بالاضافه الى 30 ساعه تخصصيه من التخصص
الاخر ويدون كلا التخصصين في وثيقه التخرج
بينما التخصص الفرعي والذي يطلق عليه فهو
ايضا برنامج اكاديمي يطيح للطالب دراسه
اكثر من تخصصين في نفس الوقت
التخصص فرعي بالاضافه الى التخصص الرئيسي
ويدون التخصص الفرعي في السجل الاكاديمي
للطالب طبعا كمرحله اوليه نحن نطرح
برنامجين مزدوجين وببرمجين فرعيين لهذا
الفصل الدراسي ونركز فيها على الدمج بين
التخصص تقنيه المعلومات والصحه العامه مع
الاداره واداره اداره الاعمال وايضا
الماليه
العربيه استطاعت اراء الناس حول التخصصات
المزدوجه والتخصصات الفرعيه نشاهد
ويساعده بحياتها
وانا ان شاء الله يعني ان الجامعات تتعود
على هالشيء
وخطوه مره جيده واحسن يعني اني كنت شخص
عنده اختيارات بدال ما يكون عنده خيار
واحد ويحترم الموضوع اتخصص من شغلتين ممكن
احبها ممكن تكون شيء اهلي
حابينه واسوي لهم اياه والثانيه كموهبه
انا حبتها اني اتخصص فيها قرار ممتاز جدا
ممتاز انه يكون الواحد عنده فرصه يعني لو
ما حالف الحظ على
التخص اللي معاه الاول يجب التخصص ثاني
الفكره جيده ممتازه ويا ريت يعني تكون كل
الجامعات تطبق ذا القرار كتير حلوه هيك
بتعطي مجال للكل انه ليقدر يعمل توميز
وهيك ما يكون محصور بوحده ولا يقدر انه
ياخذ شغل اداره ويترقى باكثر اسرع مع اكثر
خبرات
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تقويم الرياض يوفر اكثر من 185 الف وظيفه
مباشره وغير مباشره خلال ثمانيه اشهر
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد سجلت السعوديه مستوى
قياسيا في متوسط هطول الامطار باكثر من 31
مليمتر في ابريل والذي يعد الاعلى منذ
اربعين عاما وفقا لوزاره البيئه والمياه
والزراعه
[موسيقى]
من نعناع سيلتحق بنا نائب رئيس جمعيه
الطقس والمناخ الدكتور عبد الله المسند
الدكتور عبد الله مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض اريد السؤال بدايه عن
اب اسباب هذا الهطول الغزير للامطار في
شهر ابريل للسعوديه والذي يعني تقول
التقديرات بانه غير مسبوق منذ اربعين عاما
اسعد الله مساء الجميع هذه نعمه من الله
سبحانه وتعالى اذ ان هذا الموسم الموسم
المطري الذي بدا في اكتوبر عام 22 ومستمر
حتى الان ولن ينتهي باذنه تعالى الا
بنهايه هذا الشهر شهر مايو هو في الواقع
موسم مطري غزير ونستطيع القول انه
استثنائي سواء على مستوى القيم
والارقام التي تم تسجيلها في المحطات
المطريه او على مستوى ذكريات كبار السن او
حتى على مستوى جريان الاوديه وعلى مستوى
ايضا الربيع الذي انتشر في معظم المناطق
فهو استثنائي وما ذاك الا بسبب ان الله
سبحانه وتعالى
قدر العوامل التي تضافرت سواء كانت من
البوابه الشماليه الغربيه التي تاتي منها
السحب والمخفضات الجويه التي تؤثر على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او البوابه
الجنوبيه الغربيه التي ايضا تاتي من اواسط
افريقيا ومن بحر العرب ومن ثم
تؤثر على امطار المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فكانت
المثاليه في الاحوال الجويه والعناصر
الجويه منذ دخول ولا كنت موسم الامطار في
اكتوبر الماضي دكتور هل يمكن الجسم بتاثير
برنامج الاستمطار الحالي على هذه الكميه
الغزيره من الامطار
نتائج الاستمطار ان لا يمكن ان
نقول انها ناجحه او غير ذلك من خلال موسم
واحد لذلك استغرب من الاخوه في وزاره
البيئه او المركز الوطني للارصاد ان
اعلنوا النتائج قبل نهايه الموسم الموسم
بقي فيه شهر مايو ومع ذلك اعلان النتائج
ان كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه اتوقع انه يفترض
ان تكون هناك جهه محايده جهه اخرى هي التي
تقوم بتقييم هذا العمل وهذه العمليات
الاستمطار الذي تم في هذا في هذا الموسم
كثير يا دكتور يتحدث عن التغير المناخي
الذي يحدث في العالم سواء بارتفاع درجات
الحراره بانخفاضها بزياده كميه الامطار
ربما بالقحط في اماكن كذلك اخرى هل ما
يحدث من تغير مناخي في العالم له ارتباط
بما يحدث من كميه امطار وهطولها بهذا
الشكل الغزير وهل هو ايجابي اصلا لمنطقتنا
منطقه الخليج العربي
الاحترار العالمي والتغير المناخي امر
ملموس في الواقع ومصور ومسجل وعليه
الاتفاق بغض النظر عن اسباب هذا التغير
فيما يتعلق بارتفاع درجه الحراره والتي
تعاني منه او يعاني منه كوكب الارض فهذا
امر سلبي سواء كان على الحيوان او النبات
او حتى الانسان وايضا حتى الجمادات اما
فيما يتعلق بعنصر الامطار فمن الصعوبه
بمكان ان نقول ان التغير المناخي سيؤثر
ايجابا على كميات الامطار التي سوف تعطل
في المستقبل على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اذ ان النماذج المناخيه لم تتفق حتى الان
هي لا مستقبل الامطار في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نظرا لصعوبه
التوقعات في مثل هذا العنصر المطري وان
كانت المؤشرات الاوليه تشير الى حد ما الى
امر ايجابي بارتفاع يقدر بنسبه معينه وهذا
ليس عليه الاتفاق كما ذكرت اشكرك جزيلا
الشكر من عنيزه نائب رئيس جمعيه الطقس
والمناخ الدكتور عبد الله المسند شكرا يا
دكتور
اولى الظواهر الطبيعيه بدايه فصل الصيف هي
الغبار ينقسم الى قسمين عابر ودائم
التفاصيل في التقويم مع خالد
[موسيقى]
شعاع الشمس بحيث اننا نشاهد الشمس مثل
البدر بدون شعاع هذا يدل على كثافه الغبار
وهذا يصير بول الصيف كنه ثريا امور بعنيه
الجيض والدوائر المحيطه حوالين البدر هذا
يدل على غزاره الرطوبه وهذا يكون في عز
القيظ ددحه وجمره القيظ الجوزه الملزم
التليبين وزرقه وجه السماء هذا يدل على
شده البروده وهذا يكون في عز الشتاء
المربعانيه والشرط هكذا كان اهالينا
يعرفون الاجواء عن طريق الظواهر المشاهده
فهم يهتدون بهذه العلامات كهتداء العمياني
في الطريق وعلامات وبالنجم هم يهتدون
[موسيقى]
ومن الظواهر الطبيعيه التي تحدث في اول
الصيف كحال ايامنا هذه هو الغبار والغبار
ينقسم الى قسمين غبار عابر وغبار دائم
العابر هو الغبار الذي ينتقل من منطقه الى
منطقه تاليه او الغبار السابق للحالات
المطريه والمصاحب للرياح الهابطه والغبار
الدائم هو الغبار اللصيق على وجه السماء
والذي يستمر لمده ثلاثه شهور تقريبا يحصل
على اليمن وجنوب السعوديه نواحي المناطقه
تهاميه على جازان جواد لا يزل له عثار
وجاري لا يشق له غبار
[موسيقى]
حقق تقويم الرياضه الذي تنفذه الهيئه
العامه للترفيه خلال ثمانيه اشهر الماضيه
حقق اكثر من 185 الف وظيفه بمختلف
المجالات حيث اكد رئيس مجلس اداره الهيئه
العامه للترفيه المستشار التركي للشيخ على
ان فعاليات تقويم الرياضه وفرت اكثر من
185 الف وظيفه مباشره وغير مباشره لشباب
وفتيات السعوديه هذا ويتضمن تقويم الرياض
فعاليات مستمره طوال العام تحتوي على
مجموعه من الاحداث والفعاليات الترفيهيه
المتنوعه
قبل ختام الرابعه هذه ابرز عناوينها
مرشح للانتخابات التركيه الخاسر سنان اوغن
يحدد شروطه لدعم اردوغان او كليجد دار
اوغلو في جوله الاعاده
مستوى التضخم في السعوديه يستقر عند 2.7%
للشهر الثاني على التوالي
الجمارك السعوديه تحبط محاوله تهريب مليون
و300 الف حبه كبتاجون عبر ميناء جده
البيئه السعوديه تكشف عن تسجيل اعلى متوسط
لهطول الامطار منذ اربعين عاما في ابريل
الماضي
5000 ريال مخالفه عدم استخدام العنوان
الوطني من قبل مقدمي الخدمات البريديه في
السعوديه
شكرا لكم لكرم ولطف المتابعه انتهت
الرابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
اخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات